wir kommen jetzt auch gleich schon auf
die kapelle zu ja wir sehen hier welches
beatrice mit ihrem mann immer pellizotti
also die tochter von andrew und
trainieren wir auch schon gibt
zara phillips wartet dort sehr elegant
gekleidet nach dresscode immer mit
kleinen hütchen für die kirche damit
tragen heute knielang das war eben
übrigens die tochter von sophie wessex
louise windsor wird das ist kate niedrig
jahren wie immer sehr elegant verneigen
sich alle nur den kopf in der sache
vorbeigeht
camilla
[Musik]
und wir haben sie ihn angesprochen unter
der trauergemeinde auch drei gäste aus
deutschland was prinz philip
ausdrücklich verfügt hat im deutschen
wurzeln über seine schwestern die alle
in deutsche adelshäuser ein geheiratet
haben
also durften sie haben noch nicht dabei
sein die familie aus so scheerer große
er um einen eklat zu vermeiden weil es
schon auch verbindung zu den
nationalsozialisten gab aber philipp hat
sich sehr dafür engagiert dass das
verhältnis auch von england zu
deutschland hier sehen wir die queen ist
ausgestiegen aus dem land rover betritt
ihr schwerster gang apple-geschäft gang
[Musik]
queen wird da drin alleine sitzen
das ist aufgrund von corinna
bestimmungen so sie hat jetzt niemand
werde ihre kammer frau im auto dabei
aber wirklich karriere wird sie alleine
kommt jack miller mit abstand haut ihr
hier
müller ok-team gehen die damen alle mit
ihr durch die galilei coach sophie von
wessex hat man doch gesehen hast du alle
zwei wochen im artikel groß geschriebene
so viel es ist ihre art neue vertrauten
ja eine sehr sehr enge verbindung haben
so viel und die queen in den letzten
jahren aufgebaut weil so viel sie sehr
zurückhaltend sehr diskret hier wurden
jetzt schon wir sehen in der formation
die plätze tauschen jetzt geht william
sozusagen hinter peter philips harry
geht hinter peter philips und seinem
großen bruder kurieren das weckt
erinnerungen an das ergebnis mit diesem
brief mami wisst ihr damals noch auf
ihrem sag ich kann nicht lesen ist davon
in dieser welt obwohl es auch von den
äckern
man kann es nicht ändern es sind auch
noch keine informationen verfügbar
darüber was wer von wem und was drin
steht sie sind ja sich jetzt im
sogenannten hornschuh kloster das ist
der kreuzgang vor dem west zu toren
dort werden die daten der erzbischof von
canterbury und der din
von der swatch chef also der kirche
genau die werden ihnen dort in empfang
nehmen und dann werden ihm zu ehren wird
um punkt 16 uhr unserer zeit an
nationale schweigeminute stattfinden
meint sozusagen in 96 minuten mit ganz
großbritannien still stehen jetzt der
blick in die das ist das chorgestühl wir
sehen oben die flaggen der ritter des
hosenbandordens und die queen nimmt im
platz
das sogenannte westtor der
hosenbandordens es klingt immer so so
witzig aber es ist ein sehr hoch
dekorierter orden einer der exklusivsten
jahre alt und ganz kleine hunde und
manchmal kurz
das ist echt
er ist er aus der seemannssprache das
hat er sich gewünscht er war ja
marineoffizier
[Musik]
borken
200 200 kilo schwer mit blei ausgegossen
besser für die konjunktur wirken
wichtiges thema na ja klar weil wir
wissen ja dass philipp jetzt zwar
vorerst seine ruhe finden würden nicht
seine letzte mission
denn der sarg wird nicht dort bleiben wo
er nach hessen gebracht wird sondern er
wird mit dem tod von der queen noch
einmal verlegt werden erwartet auch
seine die asylanten olibet im tod werden
sie noch einmal verein gerade wieder
vereint
usd er trägt
das ist jetzt die neue energie zu ehren
battle cry an kampfschrei aus der
sprache der navy pfeift das hat ja auch
so verfügt das ist wie gesagt hier das
westtor der chapel wir haben so viele
hochzeiten an diesem tor gesehen
glückliche bereute rauskommen sehen
heute eben ein sehr viel trauriger
anders oben wird der sarg von bischof
canterbury entgegengenommen derweil
nimmt die queen schon platz im
chorgestühl vorne und dann die nationale
schweigeminute
wir sehen hier die visionen der
verschiedenen regimenter
vom highlander bataillon aus schottland
aus der royal navy household cavalry das
sind die mit den spitzen glänzenden
metall haut mit puschel dran
gerade links im bild zu sehen also die
reiterstaffel wie steht jetzt im bild
links
[Musik]
es ist ja alles im zeichen der sie heute
noch alles im zeichen des sees und der
meere sozusagen weil er ja eben auch ein
seemann war
das ist hier in seiner standarte nochmal
das ist das etwa schloss
es werden ja keine predigten behalten
heute und es wird auch nicht alle
seniorinnen aufgrund von kuwait eben nur
der kurve singen
unter anderem werden stücke von johann
sebastian bach gespielt
auch das musikprogramm hat er verfügt
nur keine reden von fünf schüssen
müsste gleich auch die schweiz beginnen
wie spät ist es 16 uhr
ja das ist die schweigeminute ich kann
die branche nicht sehen die die königin
trägt aber sieht sehr nach der branche
nach besagter branche aus die schon mal
angesprochen hat als geste an trends
fälle
das ganze land steht jetzt still schweiz
in gedenken an prinz philip das ist der
mann von prinzipien der zweite ja wer
mit dem sie wirklich richtig glücklich
ist
tim lorenz
es ist im übrigen gerade flug fort das
ist ja handy horn die rossoneri gibt
gibt alles es ist gerade flugverbot über
dem schloss windsor castle legte direkt
in der einflugschneise von hieß es
du kannst also alexander bestätigen
können wenn du da bist ein eigenes wort
oft nicht verstehen die gemälde und
wackeln an den schloss wenden
sie haben extra viele sind heute
sechsminütige flugverbotszone
eingerichtet um diese schweigeminute und
den feierlichen einzug in die kapelle
nicht zu stören und du siehst die das
ist da die langen break da ist die
hotellerie positioniert also an der
themse es sind die räume ist jetzt den
sarg tragen werden zum altar seinen
letzten aktiven termine vor
zurückgetreten ist 217 sozusagen hat er
eben auch bei diesem regiment absolviert
also das ist ein herzens regiment ganz
besondere beziehung dazu schon gesagt er
war seemann sein sein motiv der
bloodhound mit dem er immer mit den
kindern auch in den ferien zum segeln
gefahren ist also das war eine ganz ganz
große leidenschaft mit 17 eingetreten
als mir ins militär und dann werden ja
auf dem altar in der kapelle neuen
kissen platziert werden
auf dem eine auswahl seiner mithalten
und anderen diktieren wird rote sand
wissen alles wurde per hand aufgenäht
alle orden alle ausschalten was hat es
mit fischen rat dir du hast doch gesagt
der bezug zur serie ein bis ins letzte
detail und zentral wird da am altar
der hosenbandordens platziert sein
es wird vermutet dass der dass philipp
mehr als 50 aus mehr auszeichnung aus
mehr als 50 ländern erhalten hat
insgesamt es gab gar nicht genug platz
um die darauf wie er musste auswählen er
musste auswählen welches ihnen die
wichtigsten sind die dort dann heute an
diesem tag an dem tag an dem die welt
abschied von dem kind platziert werden
der vor vier jahren haben wir hier im
verschleiern vor drei jahren haben wir
hier noch harry und megan fox 23 laufen
sehen
da starten dort stühle mit hunderten von
gästen heute findet alles nur im
vorderen teil in sogenannten vorraum
stadt und alle müssen was getragen auf
den 7
gesehen liegt auch sein prunk schwer hat
das gehört auch zur admirals erfahrungen
als einer uniform war
[Musik]
in der kirche sind ja auch übrigen
andere ganz prominente namen haben dort
ihre letzte ruhe gefunden unter anderem
heinrich der achter
und auch die eltern von queen elizabeth
wenn ich schon sechster und queen mum 44
könige sind doch beide sätze insgesamt
handelszahlen
schon im frühen alter von nur seit
hunderten von ihrer werden da könige ja
es ist zeit für dich
sich jetzt hin
[Musik]
der will sagt wird jetzt auf einem
cutter falk im chorgestühl aufgebahrt
werden
über der grabplatte von heinrich dem
achten
und du siehst das ist ganz faszinierend
die das sind die standarten der ritter
des hosenbandordens das rote rechts ist
der kaiser von japan
der könig von schweden hat auch seine
standarte hängen könig von norwegen der
spanische könig alle sind mitglieder des
ordens und dieser orden wird auch
prominent zentral am altar oder liegt
schon einmal zeigt nun schon gesehen da
ganz kostbare nordens kette vom heiligen
georg ja auch dem schutzheiligen dieser
kirche liegen der berühmte drachentöter
mit juwelen besetzt ein chor mit vier
sängern ist in der kirche in der chapel
die musik umfasst zum beispiel auch
johann sebastian bach werden wir hören
schmücke dich o liebe seele
[Musik]
ja
o
[Musik]
männern geben ihren frauen platz nehmen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren